welcome to a fresh take on the news
putting you at the center of the
national conversation about the issues
that matter to you most
tonight the queen absent again as prince
charles steps in to represent her
majesty at the annual commonwealth day
service
the duke and duchess of cambridge
prepare for their first caribbean tour
prince harry is criticized for not
planning to attend a memorial to his
grandfather
and the fallout continues from prince
andrews out of court settlement
i'm trevor phillips and this is the
great debate
each week we go to the heart of the
issue dominating the headlines
tonight as the queen celebrates 70 years
on the throne our viewers panel from
across the country and across the world
will tell their stories and have their
say
joining us in studio this week
roy nika royal editor at the sunday
times
norman baker former liberal democrat mp
and author of what the royal family
don't want you to know
comedian and activist grace campbell and
the journalist and commentator wesley
kerr
the big question tonight
what does the future look like for the
royal family
let's start as ever with our viewers
panel
let's talk to nicola stevenson in
newcastle indeed dame nicole stevenson
good evening
we as a nation have been served
exceptionally well by an inspirational
dignified resolute queen for over seven
decades
harmonic ready radiates calm and
leadership in the stormiest of seas
her council of prime ministers has
steered them well
prince william and kate have shown the
dedication of ship to save the country
and have won the hearts in the nation
due to their open and warm approach
my question to the panel is
how is our dedicated selfless
long-serving queen shape the future of
the royal family
thank you nichola well that's a
straightforward start for us
nicholas question is
how is the queen shaping the future of
the royal family roy nica um the
important point there being queen's
running this
absolutely and even though the queen is
nearly 96
her finger is still very much on the
tiller and i think
all the things that nicola mentioned
there about the queen being steadfast
stable but looking to the future how is
she shaping it well the queen has been
very cleverly shaping the monarchy
throughout her 70 year reign but what
we've seen i think interestingly in the
last few years is we are clearly into
the period of transition now there's no
getting away from that the queen is
still running the show there's no
suggestion of a regency or no suggestion
about abdication but she's aware that
you know
possibly the end of her reign is
not too lo too far away and so what
we've seen quite interestingly recently
are a couple of key things
she's tying up loose ends she's shaping
things for the transition of king
charles and as we've seen recently she
let it be known she wants she would like
camilla to be queen
i think the other thing in terms of her
legacy is as nicola mentioned there the
duke and duchess of cambridge the you
know the future of the royal family
what was really interesting ten years
ago
when we had that diamond jubilee
appearance of
the slimmed down monarchy which has
always been the prince of wales a sort
of
key call or thing about the future and
the queen was very interested and very
focused on sending a message that
the royal family has to change and
evolve in order to stay relevant in
order to shape the future
it's going to be smaller and she's
pushing that forwards too
okay let's come back to our viewers
panel because i think
the picture that you've painted roya
isn't is an interesting one let's say
see what zubair
khan thinks
about that zubair i think you have a
view about this
yes thank you good evening travis my
view is that the future is bright
positive and optimistic
for the monarchy the queen is a
wonderful person who has served the
nation with dignified men and it's shown
accepted leadership in terms of
diversity and i think
we should all celebrate and be proud of
what she's done for the uk and the
commonwealth and worldwide however i do
genuinely believe that going forward um
a slim down version of the monarchy
evolving with the times will be
beneficial the
the duke and duchess of cambridge will
be phenomenal for the future so we'll
prince charles will be so i think the
future is bright and we should be
pragmatic and celebrate the monarchy
thank you subair okay well uh norm baker
well there's a
a rather positive picture monarchy
queen in control
that was slim down picture and i think
it's important for the monarchy
not to assume that the good will which
exists undoubtedly for the queen on the
personal basis will necessarily transfer
to prince charles only to other members
of the royal family they have to earn
that in the same way the queen has
earned it and there's a certain concern
i have
that just resting on laurel's going on
prince charles does say he wants to slim
down the royal family he needs to do
that because the royal family is very
bloated on the front cover of my book
there are 44 of them on the balcony i
mean who are these people and why are we
paying for them
there's a need to
slim it down but there's also need to
change some of the arrangements because
we still have in many ways an imperial
monarchy unlike the ben latch countries
unlike the scandinavian countries the
rules for our royal family are set
centuries ago we need to just not simply
slim them down but eliminate the tax
breaks which they get with nobody else
has change arrangements for example
where will's a secret nobody else is
with a secret change of financial
arrangements let's just remember that
the royal family here costs 83 million
pounds of thereabouts a year up from 7.9
million 10 years ago without the
security costs on top so there's need to
be reform with that as well okay
greg campbell um
where are you on all of this
monica is this slim down monarchy
no monarchy my view is no i mean i think
the monarchy is so relevant and it's a
huge part of our culture and society i
think on a wider picture i'm very anti
the way that the class system works in
this country and i think the royal
family a lot of our power structures
trickle down from that so you know like
talking about like school schooling
systems and like how many of them went
to eaton how many of our current
politicians went to eat and how many
people were in powerful positions in
this country went to one school i hate
the concentration of power and i do
think the royal family has a massive
part to play in that so you can't blame
the royal family for that right i think
no but the purpose of it is essentially
it plays into the idea that we've got a
hierarchy in this country we've got
aristocracy we've got a system in which
people are born into a family get more
wealth privileges like norman's just
said because of whether what family they
were born into that it does come from
the system at which the royal family is
at the top okay let's um
let's go to barnes league david
petherbridge
what do you reckon
well i'm interested they're talking
about this this money situation i
noticed neither of them have mentioned
the the amount of money that was brought
into this country because of the royalty
don't tell me they come just to see um
just to see bits and pieces of this
country they come because the royal
family is here and they respect it
let's bring in stephen fairley
stephen
well you heard what david had to say
what do you think
well i've heard what everybody said and
uh
i think the monarchy should end when the
queen's when the queen's
rain ends i think the monica should end
um
this might sound harsh but the the heirs
are not up to the task they're not up to
the job of taking on i mean
what your your column has said that the
royal family you know the queen is built
up you know a big
you know a big royal family you know
passing but i think theirs are just not
up to the job and i think it represented
an out-of-date institution and it
shouldn't exist in the 21st century they
should not be paying taxes
to keep one family and their heirs which
is numerous to live in policies and have
private jets however it spends just
because of a bloodline wesley carr i
think it's great that there's a debate
and in fact to me that the debate shows
the relevance of the institution and the
monarchy as as always um because it's a
constitutional monarchy it's always
capable of being shaped and changed i
don't agree with some of norman's
figures i think he wasn't comparing
light would like i think some of the
costs he's talking about are the costs
for example for repairing buckingham
palace which whether there was a
monarchy or not presumably you would
keep buckingham palace i think that
there would be a class system if there
wasn't a monarchy i would say that
france is not without a class system the
united states is not without a class
system so i don't think that's very
different though i don't think the two
go together i might um so i i think
actually it's an institution which is
useful but but it but it must reform so
it's constantly reformed during the
queen's reign and i think when there's a
new raid there'll be an opportunity to
look at all this stuff but norman was
saying for example there were 44 people
on the balcony but very few of those are
in receipt of public funds so
at the key balconies there's probably
about six or seven in receipt of public
funds and they work hard and on the
money thing i think the prince's trust
in the last 10 years has bought in over
a billion pounds okay and this this
brand is very valuable to the country
and it brings us all together and it
remains popular reinika is um reform
plausible
depends what kind of reform we were
talking about i think reform is already
underway um we talked about you know
norman very keen to see slowing down the
monarchy the monarchy is being slimmed
down
not in the way that anyone anticipated
we've seen three senior members step
back and step away in the last two years
prince andrew and the sussexes um so
going forwards we are going to have a
reformed one you know and i think under
king charles and this is something i've
you know written about we are going to
see reform he's going to open up the
palaces open up the private residences i
think he'll do a lot more i think
things are changing um in terms of
should we still have a monarchy you know
i i keep a close eye on the polls
constantly you know week week by week
this country is being published to
whether or not he wants to retain a
monarchy and there's always an
overwhelming majority in terms of of
retaining a monkey so i don't think we
will see the monkey disappear
but i think in order for it to survive
and thrive
um
things are going to have to change under
the reign of king charles and i think
they will all right i'm going to come
back to not make non-bacon a second but
just uh steven fairley i think you're
still with us
um
seems like the weight of opinion
is against your view
that we should
get rid of the monarchy uh would you
would you ever settle for
the sort of reform that roy and nick has
just been talking about
like a slowing down monarchy yeah
i think um i think the debate is you
know it should be that you know if
that's one of the options i think that
i mean what else can we do you know i
mean we don't have the powers
to remove them so i don't know if
there's an opt you know even an opt-out
you know if people want to i would
rather my tax money went to
something else than to keep people in
policies and private jets it's just the
way i feel i don't mind paying that
money but i don't want to pay it towards
towards that i'd rather pay towards the
nhs all right so thank you thank you
stephen norman baker i want to come back
on buckingham palace both i think it was
david and barnsley and wesley over here
have raised it first of all up until the
end of georgia texas reign
all buckingham palace cost were paid by
the monarch not by the public purse
secondly we were told as
parliamentarians in 2010 we needed 10
million pounds to prepare buckingham
palace the bill has now reached 359
million pounds for an all whistles bells
refurbishment and in terms of the
argument that they bring in tourists i
don't really think we should base our
constitutional arrangements on what the
tourists like in any case if we do which
is the palace in europe with the most
visitors the palace of versailles and
the french according to the monarch in
1842 we should base our constitutional
arrangements on what the public like it
remains popular at any time a political
party the liberal party we shouldn't be
at any time party could put in its
manner
let me let me just go back to the public
and talk to
uh not tran knock
me personally i think like the royal
family they it is unfair to say that
they don't contribute into these
countries it's it's been years they've
been you know they've been serving the
queen's been serving her whole family
has been serving uh you know generations
to come they've done amazing work both
at home and abroad i think somebody
mentioned about the class system
and then you say that remove the royal
family would just literally
eliminate the class system i don't think
so even you go to america in france it's
still the same thing rich families they
still want their kids to inherit they
still want their kids to go to private
school they don't want their kids to go
to
state school so even if you remove the
royal family it doesn't change anything
that's the way how life works
grace campbell well i wasn't saying that
if you got rid of the royal family the
class system would end that's absolutely
i'm not stupid i'm well aware i also
don't think we should abolish the
monarchy what i'm saying is i think that
the royal family and people like boris
johnson 64 of his cabinet right now went
to private schools it trickles down i
think they need to acknowledge that much
more rather than act like they're like
the rest of us or you know i think we do
have a different class system here than
in the us 100 because of the way that
social mobility works from working class
people to getting into the white house
that doesn't happen here in the same way
because we have such a deep rooted
classes which i actually think more
comes from
the schooling system to be honest which
you know in my dream world the royal
family would send their kids to state
schools that would be great okay we will
agree yeah because that would be a great
way of sending a message yeah that we
believe in the state power we believe in
the state
schools
i'm saying that's not my point i'm
saying i really think if they wanted to
make a big move and say
we totally are trying to modernize and
we are progressive that would be an
amazing
great danger there's great danger of
consensus here from mexic to prince
andrew's court case the royal family has
been hit by a series of scandals in
recent years
and while the palace has worked hard to
mitigate the damage there's little doubt
the firm's been affected by the intense
focus and immediate coverage
i want to come to our viewers panel and
talk to lee diebel who is in maidstone
lee you've got a question for our panel
i have a big fan of the world family but
with the outcomes
of cases uh in the past prince andrew
uh cash for honours with prince charles
and certainly the race is claimed by
prince harry and meghan markle
my question to the you and the panel is
can the world family be trusted and
looked upon as role models anymore
thank you lee
interesting
lee's question is
following recent scandals should the
royals still be considered good role
models grace campbell
well i think
it's hard after what's happened with
prince andrew for me to say that i've
what's happened with him i think is
again like coming back to the system
that we have in this country of powerful
men abusing their power doing things
that they think they can get away with
because they're rich and can pay people
off and have status and whatever we
should be clear that he has denied
of course but we should also be clear
that he paid 12 million
dollars or pounds potentially yeah
pounds to shut someone up so i'm not
sure that's
guilt
moving on but i'm saying what i'm saying
is no i don't think that's a terrible
terrible look for them and they know
that which is why as you said they are
slimming the fat that wasn't an
intentional fat slimming that was them
saying we have to shut this up and
separate ourselves from him right now on
the flip side what happened with harry
and megan yeah that's a bad look if all
of those claims are true that harry
megan have said happened
that's a bad look for them my people
that i know
people my age everyone i follow on
social media after that people really
really started to see them in a much
darker light so i'm not sure that they
are role models right now no i don't
know how we can relate to them in that
way they've had a completely different
set of circumstances to us um i know
that they used to play this role of
being a sort of perfect family that we
should look to for stability but how can
we do that when the queen's supposedly
favorite son
has done what he's done
this is an important point to roy that
uh
through most of the 20th century the
royal family in a sense represented the
ideal of
the upper middle class british family
i i i would turn this question on its
head and say
do we do we really want them to be do
they do they want to be role models i
think the queen sort of sits above the
rest of the family in terms of for the
last 70 years people have
looked to see what she does rather than
what she says she's very careful what
she does and doesn't say but i think
beyond that i'm not sure we should hold
the royal family up to your role models
and i don't think they want to be either
they are there to do what they can with
their elevated position in terms of
shining a spotlight on things but i
don't think they hold themselves up as
role models i think we
you know there's no doubt that the duke
of york the issue's there that has
damaged the brand no one looks to him as
a role model but i think moving forward
this is all part of the evolution after
the queen
the queen is sort of sit separately as a
sort of paragon of stability
but i don't think the prince of wales
down i don't think they want to be held
up as role models they just want to do
the right thing when they can alright
well let's talk to some people for whom
role models are supposed to matter let's
talk to some
young viewers uh isha gill
who is a regular viewer it's good to see
you again isha what's um what's your
view
um well i definitely do question whether
we need a royal family and i think a lot
of the younger generation do
and especially with all the controversy
surrounding prince andrew you know we
have to question whether the system is
archaic and whether there is a place in
modern society
for an unelected family to rule the
nation but i do think it is important to
acknowledge that the queen is a
dedicated and good figurehead
but in my opinion she just manages a
business i mean we do refer to it as the
firm
and i personally don't think she's gone
through any more hardship than any other
family you know why are they supposedly
above or better than us i don't think
that's right that's an interesting
concept that uh the queen indeed they
called it further she manages business
but
let's let's talk to another uh teenager
connor summer uh somehow
connor what do you make of it
well i think we should keep the royal
family i think they're important they
are role models
i'd like to question what i always just
said about rule i don't think they do
rule i think they kind of watch over
more than rule because they don't
have any political power in terms of if
they crossed off a law that was passed
they're just they'd be out crying that
could be the end of them
also the fact that they're our cake i
think is part of the reason why we need
them because they do
kind of suggest tradition and for more
than a thousand years kind of
the story of our nation
eater
does that make you think again
um well i do acknowledge that things in
this country are based on tradition but
just because something is based on
tradition doesn't mean that it's right
or doesn't mean that it should be kept
in the modern world
you know we we advance and we change as
a nation and i think the monarchy you
know it has to adapt or you know it may
it may just go
okay but you guys stay there uh wesley i
i think yes they are
this is the future
i think i think connor and esha are both
16 or 17. but have different views but
yes they are a firm um
yes they are a firm and a business but
at the service of the nation and the
commonwealth and like any family there
are weak links certainly andrew's not a
role model
um i think the other allegations the
cash for honors that that's not clear
precisely what happened there
and and and and is is there's a police
inquiry but i don't think that we can
accuse prince charles of of of any
misdemeanor there
i think megan and harry i was not
particularly clear what the allegation
of racism was in terms of the precise
allegation i think it was a very
imprecise allegation and that's hard to
fight back well to be clear duchess of
sussex said that somebody said to her
husband that uh they wondered what color
their child would be and she took that
as uh a sign of a
anti-a racist view
we don't know who said it or what
precisely was said i think if you're
going to make a serious allegation and i
don't think they you they um you've got
to make a specific allegation so i
wasn't entirely convinced by that and
having met most the members of the royal
family having been with the queen for
several weeks in the caribbean working
dutifully from eight in the morning to
11 at night i didn't i've never sensed
the scintilla of racism from the family
but i think i think these are questions
that need to be asked they must be
accountable it's a constitutional
monarchy so the debate in itself is very
worthwhile nom baker one of the things
we do know is that the duke of sussex
harry
has decided that he won't be here
for
the memorial
to his grandfather uh
as grace to use grace's expression a
moment ago not a good look well it's not
a good look but i mean ultimately i
think it's up to him um it's a family
mata and he wants to turn up he should
turn up if he doesn't he doesn't but
coming back to the point about the role
models i mean going back to beginning
the queen's reign a third of the
population that was polled said they
thought the queen was appointed by god
that was a view in 1952 from the british
population and they were presented as a
kind of
role model family now that's all fallen
apart a bit you couldn't by the way meet
the queen if you were a divorced person
in 1952 good thing i didn't apply to
your own family because a lot's happened
since then but i think what's what we
have to realize is they are human
they're going to be full of like any
family people who are worthy and people
who aren't worthy that's any family so
let's move forward on that basis but the
problem has been that i think members of
the royal family have hidden behind the
queen who has been seen to be faultless
in many people's eyes and they've
assumed that they can get away with it
but hiding behind her skirt and they
aren't we've talked about prince andrew
prince charles is subject him and his
foundation are subject to a formal
police inquiry for this business of cash
run as a consequence by itself okay and
we need to find out what the result of
the inquiry we do but i mean it's not a
good to pick up um gracious phrases not
a good look is it for the throne to be
subject to it but it also shows he's not
above the law the fact that there is an
inquiry he's had to you know lose an
aide he's not above the law and that the
inquiry will proceed
there is going to be more to this than
the personalities we need to come back
to the institution itself
the duke and duchess of cambridge will
visit jamaica next week as part of their
first official tour of the caribbean the
country could be the next commonwealth
nation to replace the queen as head of
state and become a republic following in
the footsteps of barbados before we come
back to our viewers panel we're joined
from bridgetown in barbados by cynthia
barrow giles professor of political
science at the university of the west
indies
good afternoon professor um
what do you think the chances are that
the jamaicans will take the lead that
barbados has offered
um thank you very much for that question
i think it's an important one
as we all know
the
decision of the barbados government to
transit to a republic has in fact been
met with a lot of i think a lot of
people in ukraine have actually welcomed
the decision of the barbados government
and i and and certainly no other country
in the caribbean um more so than jamaica
has shown an inclination to once again
embrace discussion around
republicanism i would say to you however
that i do not anticipate that any
transition to republicanism in jamaica
and it appears to be on the table will
in fact take place within the next year
or so largely because unlike barbados um
there is only uh constitutional
requirement for a referendum to take
place so it is a
two-step process all like barbados which
did not have to in fact engage with the
um the referendum it's interesting
because um uh
you can't see me but the country that my
family come from which is guyana uh
went
for a republic now what 50 years ago and
there's always been this sentiment in
the caribbean what drives it do you
think
what drives a desire to um become a
republic i think to a large extent if we
look if we go back to the discussions
taking place in the caribbean all the
way back to the 1930s and 1940s for
instance there was a thinking on the
part of the caribbean political leaders
at the time that was important for us to
in fact embark upon independence no
doubt at the time there was the view
also that it would not have been
possible for us to achieve independence
within the context of a republic but
certainly in the last the last seven or
so decades but um more so in the last
three decades um
most caribbean countries have felt that
it is very ironic that you have an
independent country with a head of state
for all for all practical reasons that
is a non-national and to that extent
when you look at the debates taking
place in the caribbean and political
leaders of course like the prime
minister of barbados have always couched
the discussion within the context of
having a local as a head of state rather
than a foreign um a foreigner as the
head of state in the country that's part
and parcel of discussions and a
narrative that has taken place in the
caribbean
professor thank you so much for your
time much appreciated
thank you very much um all the best
thank you
let's go back to the viewers panel and
talk to john
soderbergh
john um
what do you make of this
yeah good evening trevor and good
evening uh to the panel uh well uh the
commonwealth was built by erroneous
occupation uh over a few hundred years
wasn't it uh which should no longer have
any form of british ownership
connotations however i do believe it
will exist in the immediate future
although all former dependencies uh
should be self-determinant and like
barbados i believe should remove the uk
monarch from the head of state and i'm a
royalist by the way
but my question to the panel is in this
context does the panel think it's time
to modernize the commonwealth
thank you very much john and just to be
clear
becoming a republic doesn't necessarily
mean you have to leave the commonwealth
but john's question is is it time to
modernize the commonwealth norman baker
i think the copper belt's probably quite
a good thing and it ends up bringing
countries together in a non-threatening
way to discuss issues where those
countries are very different in terms of
their population their history and
everything else so i think the
commonwealth is something to be
maintained and like any institution it
needs to move with the times otherwise
it becomes fossilized i think the issue
about whether we have a head of state i
mean i think it's a bit peculiar to have
a head of state from outside your own
country that's not about the royal
family by the way that's simply about
your own country and i have always
wondered why countries like australia
have the queen's head of state we would
find it rather odd if we had an
australian head of state wouldn't we
okay let's come back to our viewers
panel um
porsha
what do you think about this issue of
the royal family commonwealth
commonwealth countries and their
independence
thank you trevor
i first came to the uk in 2002 to sing
at the opening of the commonwealth games
which was an amazing honor
i love the queen the royal family and
the common world and believe they've
done so much good for african countries
the uk and the world
i think it's a huge shame that zimbabwe
left the commonwealth because there were
a lot of pecks of being part of the
global community it was much easier to
get a visa to visit the uk when we're
part of the commonwealth
okay portuguese
wesley what do you do you agree with
that i think it's worth remembering the
commonwealth is a free association yes
two and a half billion people 54 nations
of which only 14 have the the british
monarch's head of state and that's their
choice so it's evolved enormously from
in effect it was the end of empire when
the queen took over in 1952 she was only
five years being off empress of india
which seems completely mad so so it has
evolved enormously but it's evolved by
the choice of the nations together and
individually so so jamaica my family
from jamaica i don't feel that jamaica
is lacking in independence or feistiness
countries which have the monarch as head
of state in effect do have a local head
of state they have a governor general
who does almost all the duties but when
i was in jamaica with the queen and it
was her sick visit she was clearly a
popular figure the politicians 30 years
ago wanted to remove her as head of
state let them have the referendum let
it be the people's choice but i think
anything in this modern world that
brings people together in a free
association and which turns the bad of
the empire into good cooperation i think
that's a very very powerful thing as
we've seen at westminster abbey today
okay back on the wall
i'm going to talk to tarik ali uh tarek
i think you have a slightly different
view than porsha gonzora
yeah good good evening to everybody um
i'm a bit worried that when the queen's
gone
there's nobody of the same caliber left
in the royal family to take after her
even though she's respected for her age
and what she represents and what she
does for the country
i don't think there's anyone left to
follow her example
i feel that this could be the beginning
of the end of the royal family right
nick you're um you're actually going to
be
with
the cambridges in
the caribbean
next week happy to talk with you if you
want but um what do you what do you
think is going to happen with all of
this these are some really interesting
questions and i actually was in barbados
with the prince of wales for the handler
which was fascinating
i think um look my my personal opinion
is
i think
when
we have transition and a change of rain
i do think um some of the realms i've
been to over the years have more than a
decade i do think there is a real
feeling amongst a lot of those realms
from the big ones to australia to the
smaller island nations
that um a lot of them are retaining our
head of their our head of state as
theirs um out of respect to the queen i
think there will be an absolute sea
change in terms of reconsideration of
that
the other point just to go back to the
question
should the commonwealth be reforming and
evolving and renewing itself
the commonwealth had a huge opportunity
in the 2018 commonwealth house of
government meeting here
it had an enormous opportunity to do
that
and there was discussion about who the
next head of the commonwealth would be
the queen is currently the head of the
commonwealth the prince of wales does
not inherit that automatically from his
mother
and yet
at that head of government meeting we
are told by the then prime minister
theresa may that all
heads of state agreed that the prince of
wales should be the next head of the
commonwealth so that was really
interesting to me because the
commonwealth could have selected someone
else there was no other front-runner
from any other country putting
themselves forwards they chose that
being the problem the question is what
else do you do but there was a great
opportunity there anyone could have put
themselves forward they didn't so
barbados is interesting because when i
was there speaking to people on the
ground
they were pro
moving forwards having their own
governor general as president as as head
of state but they were very keen on on
continuing the links with the
commonwealth and the queen and the
prince of wales being the next head of
that commonwealth so there's a really
interesting thing going on there that i
think they feel they want some sort of
protective arm around them in the long
run but i think but
to go back to your core question i think
a lot of realms
will derail or can seriously consider it
when the queen's 14 still right but
it'll be fine because this will be their
choice great grace campbell
you're probably going to be here longer
than the rest of us thanks
[Laughter]
what do you think about this issue of
the commonwealth well i i actually have
a question when you say people could put
themselves forward who would who would
that be prime ministers of countries or
anyone absolutely i could have done it
an elderly statesman from any of the
countries
there was a school of thought in
barbados that said replace the queen
with rihanna but do you think but do you
think that actually we could be in a
situation where all those countries
simply say we don't want a queen anymore
we still want to be part of the
commonwealth but
would that matter would that matter to
you it has it does have a rotating chair
it's it's quite a complicated
institution so it does have a rotating
chair who is one of the prime ministers
or presidents anyway my answer is um i
i think at the moment aside from just
the queen
we are quite an embarrassing country to
be associated with so if i was some of
the people from some of these countries
i might want to sabotage with us
supporting charities is an important
part of the duties carried out by
working members of the royal family from
museums to hospitals and wildlife
centers
thousands of organizations benefit from
the royal stamp of approval
jan swaby you're in peterborough
and i think you've got a view about this
point
well i'm personally not a royalist but i
do think that the royal family has a
place in our country's future
um it's part of our heritage and culture
and i think it's important for tourism
and also important with the work that
they do do for charity
i do agree with prince charles's plans
for the monarchy but i think that the
royal family would be more relevant with
a younger monarch and that prince
charles should step aside for prince
william to take the throne but actually
my question for the panel is should we
refuse to reduce the number of working
royals and streamline the monarchy
okay
jan's question for our panel should we
reduce the number of working royals and
streamline the monarchy where's the
curve it's happening anyway so you've
got a generation
retiring or like the the kents and the
gloucesters in their 70s and 80s
interesting autobiography coming out
from the duke of kent later later this
year
you you've got the three who who've left
the sussex and andrew for different
reasons
i i i think edward and sophie are
not doing more but we're seeing more of
their good work and does vast numbers of
investitures so i think i think they're
very useful members so you you still but
i think we are down to a core really of
about half a dozen
and i and i think that's about right but
i think the point about
uh adjusting the charitable work to
connect with with new things and to
connect with young people is very
important only 30 million of us are
gardeners so it's great for me involved
with the horticulture or whatever to see
the charles and the queen
involved in that actually kate but but
they've got to be new charities and i
think the attention mental health
terrific camilla osteoporosis so i think
it's got to constantly evolve but it's
got to keep up with society so i suppose
a family on the throne can reinvent
themselves and i think you'll get
different members appealing to different
generations
as the older ones
move on let's thought this 60s and 70
year olds and princess anne is the busy
i think she's still the busiest royal
isn't she yes all right let's come back
to our war and talk to andrew
your and you um i think
you've been involved with charities
which uh have royal patronage
or support at least
yeah that's correct so um i've worked in
the charity field for around about 15
years and all the charities i've worked
with they have had a connection with the
royal family um i was quite blessed in
september because i received the bem
um from the british empire medal that is
that's correct yes for the work that i
did um with the charity that i
co-founded and
um set up with my husband
um what what it's actually done for the
charity is amazing getting this beam
it's not about me it's about the charity
um and also when i was discussing with
my counterparts like some of my white
counterparts about the ben
and there was one particular friend of
mine who said that how could you accept
the
um for a second generation asian how
could you do that in terms of everything
that's happened with your parents and
what i had actually said to her was well
no
for me i'm really proud my family are
really proud as well because i worked my
you know butt off in terms of supporting
people and that's what i've always done
stay there for uh a moment andrew let's
talk to
sir brian donohoe who
uh you are a former member of parliament
so brian i think you've also had some
experience in this area i've seen it at
firsthand i've been with most of the
royals over the years of being an mp and
have
seen the good work that they do not
least the channels by virtue of the
prince's trust which i helped him with
at some points and that really looking
at what they do in that respect is just
unbelievable and indeed in one case very
close to where i stay confused house
it's been an immense input and to the
local community it has been undertaken
only because of the fact that prince
charles was involved so yes i'm a great
believer in it all i think that there is
absolutely no doubt that they're there
and very useful when that that front and
as a consequence i think that they
should be in that position for long and
many because
i tell you this there's one thing for
certain that is when it comes to the
coronation for prince charles to become
king and that's the only person that can
be then i'm sure that in every village
in every town and in every city in the
land there will be street parties out
celebrating that very fact so brian
thank you so much uh roy nick um
i wonder if this says something about us
as a nation that it takes um the status
and the
cachet and the magic of
the royal family to persuade us to do
good for other people
well you've hit the nail on the head
there trevor because i can remember
listen to all these people talking about
this issue i can remember in 2015 when i
was about to i was working on what i
knew was going to be a front page story
about william
dedicating himself in the future to
mental health
and i at the time spoke to a lot of
charities who've been plugging away on
mental health for years and many of them
said to me for years we have been trying
to get celebrities well-known figures to
get involved with our campaigns and none
of them will touch us because they are
also terrified about the taboo of mental
health and the stigma around it and what
william and harry and kate as well did
in taking up mental health and talking
about it talking about it a lot and
continuing to talk about it is they did
change they did change the dial on it
and i think that's that's key the other
thing i would say is we shouldn't just
put it into sort of generational divides
camilla dutch the cornwall she's 74 she
has
campaigned on sexual violence and
domestic abuse not the kind of things
that you might think a future queen
would be picking up and running with but
she has and that's important so
and when i the last point i would make
is that the queen is a patron of more
than 600 charities when she is no longer
around they will not all be reassigned
and i can tell you that there are
hundreds of charities who are deeply
disappointed they are not going to get
royal patronage because of the
difference they make
thank you very much indeed that
unfortunately is all we have time for
this evening
just remains for me to thank our
panelists here in the studio wesley kerr
grace campbell norman baker roy anika
of course it's you at home who are at
the center of this conversation if you'd
like to be part of the program next time
get in touch by emailing the great
debate at sky dot uk
and of course i want to thank you on the
wall our viewers who have contributed
royally yes that's a pun uh to our
conversation tonight and as ever
you're home keep talking and we'll see
you again at the same time next week for
the great debate
you